[Music]
good morning well it's almost afternoon
today is a really big day in this
pregnancy because today is my glucose
tolerance test i am now 28 weeks baby
let me show you my bare belly you guys
have never seen my bare belly yet
that's my bare belly
so 28 weeks now and what is a glucose
tolerance test okay so what i found out
is when you're pregnant you end up
creating a lot of home a lot of hormones
in your body like progesterone and
estrogen and those hormones can
sometimes block
insulin from working or like
something about insulin and something
about sugar getting into your cells like
it blocks sugar from going into your
cells and when that happens sugar lives
in your blood instead of going to your
cells so then that's how you get high
blood sugar and that is called diabetes
like between 24 weeks and 28 weeks is
when uh women tend to do this glucose
tolerance test
and the way that they generally do it is
um you go to the doctor's office and
they give you this
disgusting
disgusting bright orange drink and you
have to drink this drink and then within
the hour or something like that they
draw your blood and they see is there a
lot of sugar in your blood this drink
the reason why it's so disgusting is
like super super super sugary they're
pretty much pumping you up with a lot of
sugar to see like how does your body
react is your insulin working properly
or whatever uh and if it isn't then your
blood is going to have a lot of sugar in
it but if it is working properly then
your sugar levels will be fine so that's
what i'm doing today since i recently
switched over to a birth center i'm no
longer seeing um an md like a ob gyn or
whatever i'm now seeing a midwife and at
this particular birth center they do
this glucose tolerance test with this
thing so it's not a disgusting orange
drink it is this powder
that is um non-gmo gluten free no
additives so it's like more
like natural i guess and i get to do
this on my own like i prepare it by
myself so i got my 10 ounces of water
here i'm gonna stir this in and then
here's like the instructions because
today's december six so it says mix it
with 10 ounces of water drink within
five minutes i have to finish at the 11
30 mark it's currently 11 11 make a wish
and uh
i have to mark what time i finished so
i gotta do all this real quick and we
got the hubby here
you want to film me hubby sure i like
how you're just waiting for me to stop
talking
very important thanks i know i'm trying
to do this like as fast as i can so then
we can make it out there on time because
the appointment's at 12. okay here you
go ah sorry breath now
being so
so pregnant look at this
so pregnant beautiful it's awesome i
love it i'm loving every minute of this
pregnancy
it's going by so fast too i remember
with isaac i'm like i'm gonna be
pregnant forever it felt forever hold on
helen texted me don't look at this this
is private information it's like drink
it immediately let me make it a big deal
start
[Music]
the lady at the birth center told me too
that
this drink tastes a lot better does it
smell like
nothing
[Music]
there's no smell it smells kind of
earthy
really okay
oh my god this is significantly better
wow how come doctors don't do this
instead this is really good it's like
gatorade no not even it doesn't taste
overly sugary not fair i want some
i'm sorry
it tastes like a
freshly squeezed fruit juice if you can
get this get this
pregnant ladies out there i want to be a
pregnant lady and try it this one it's
not fair tell your doctor chug that
orange drink down the drain it's
disgusting so gross this is really good
baby you can enjoy it
a couple hours i read that it takes two
hours for them to taste what i'm eating
11 18.
nice
did it now let's go to our final
appointment at this birth center because
they notified me that they're closing in
next week next week they're shutting
down can you guys believe this i
switched over from my doctor to this
birth center and then they tell me oops
guess what we're actually going out of
business next week i'm like
what are the odds of this happening this
is crazy so now i'm in the process of
transferring over to different birth
center but this other first century
though i'm actually like this whole
thing could be a blessing in disguise
because there is a good chance that i me
might be giving birth at the birth
center there so the current one that is
closing they didn't let me birth there
because i'm having a v back which is a
vaginal birth after cesarean so they
were going to make me give birth at a
hospital which i really didn't want to
do but it was going to be with midwife
care but with this new birth center
they're like oh don't trip we do
re-backs here you don't have to go to
hospital so i'm like okay
this sunday is when i'm going to be
doing a zoom session and finding out
more so this whole baby stuff is crazy
like this is wild like what the birth
center's just closed
who does that that's crazy okay
that's we can leave
all right so while tiff is getting ready
to go to the birthing center today i
just want to give a huge shout out to
anker for sponsoring today's video anker
makes really cool portable chargers for
your phone and recently i've been using
their mango magnetic battery charger
[Music]
it's the easiest portable charger i've
ever used in my life super easy to use
all you have to do is just
click it
make sure it's aligned and it's charging
your phone the best thing about this is
that there's no need for a charging
cable anchor calls it the first adaptive
magnetic charging experience designed
for any lifestyle because all you have
to do is snap charge and go and this
thing is actually really really thin it
can fit into my pocket
how cool is that it's so thin you can
single-handedly take calls use your
camera on your phone basically use the
phone in whatever way you want while the
mag go is attached also if you're
worried about the magnets falling off
the magnets are actually very very
strong and it won't fall off so click on
the link in the description down below
and get your own mad go magnetic charger
all right time to head to the birth
center taking this bad boy i'm gonna
check up on the baby all right so we are
now on the way to the out of business
birth center now you know it's crazy
this birth center i found when we first
wanted to start getting pregnant i think
when we got married so five years ago
wow
we had a plan to get pregnant soon after
getting married and that was five years
ago no we didn't plan to get no it's
just that i was already planning because
we had always said we wanted to be
married for one year
before we started trying to get yeah
that was the plan yeah and that was 2017
to like 2018 is when we were like
supposed to like start trying or
whatever which is when we kind of did
the point is that this birth center i
found around the time that we got
married and i've been wanting to come
here since that time and now they're
going out of business like what the
universe is like you had five years to
get your business done it does make me
feel a little bit worried that a
birthing center can just close on you
like that no i get but i guess the good
thing though is the glass half full ways
of looking at it is that it could have
happened closer to our due date yeah and
i've been really stressful the fact that
we're still a good two months out um
three months actually yeah it's enough
time to re-establish our relationship
with the new
birthing center but yeah
baby's healthy i'm actually getting
way more excited about the birth now
feeling the baby kick more now i feel
like i'm able to assess the personality
of the baby to some degree now with how
the baby kicks and how often they kick
just like the baby's not moving right
now they're not like speaking to the
belly and then literally five seconds
later the baby starts moving so yeah i
guess it is responding yeah so because
of that i i i'm getting i feel closer to
this baby to me
i guess it is a baby right now huh
is it a fetus right now and then it's a
baby once it's more i don't know what
point does it become the baby
but i guess we are calling it the baby
even at the providers they're like oh
baby will need this and all that so head
is a baby okay fine we're like are you
actually
looking forward to the birth because
we've been taking birth classes recently
and you've actually gotten educated in
the entire and me too like fully
educated in the entire process the
physiological process that my body is
going to be going through to bring our
baby into this world like it's just wild
so i don't know i want to know your
thoughts on what have you been learning
like what have you been looking forward
to because it's a new experience even
for me because i've never given birth
like vaginally and learning about
how my body would do all this is like
completely new so i feel like i'm a
first time mom honestly i didn't learn
any of this when i was pregnant with
isaac so tiff and i have been taking
this birthing course
uh online birthing course we're learning
all about the misconceptions of birth
and like all like
what's happening physiologically to the
female body so like the idea is pain is
derived from fear and the fear is
derived from anxiety right and so if
you're going into the process
anxious and scared you're gonna have a
lot of fear and that fear is gonna
manifest itself in the pain and so like
there's a way to kind of degrading
tension in your body yeah so if you're
going to have negative emotions you're
going to have pain you're going to
experience negative
reactions in your body so yeah like
learning about all that it's definitely
given me a lot of confidence i was
already even before learning about the
stuff in class
i was already pretty
confident that i could manage the pain
and birth because of i don't know
because i'm weird like i just
i feel like i just have like a pretty
strong
mental strength i guess for pain or i
don't know what to call it but the point
is i've always been really looking
forward to birth but then now taking
this class and like learning about how
the fact that
endorphins release when you're happy and
grateful and
endorphins are actually pain blockers
i'm like oh my god this just makes it
even more exciting like i'm more looking
forward to
giving birth and experiencing this
euphoria of like the birth high
and like having a physiological
unmanaged
uh birth and just having like no
no interruptions like no pain management
just having myself and my own brain and
my body like just trusting my body like
i'm so excited for birth because of that
reason i don't know the way it's
explained to me like the way i'm like
grasping all these informations like
this is the moment you're gonna become a
superhero and this is the moment where
your superpowers are born you know this
is like the peter parker gets bit by a
spider tiff is gonna give give birth to
our child you know and like and this is
like the beginning of something amazing
yeah and it's not to say like
because everything you're saying like
someone can easily think of like well
she has been a mom already you know even
though i had a c-section like doesn't
make me any less of a mom and i agree i
fully agree it's just that
what we're learning right now about the
process of like the baby actually going
through the birth canal and like the
hormones that get released those get
inhibited
with a c-section through surgery too and
there's a lot of things that
like i didn't get to experience because
of the fact that i had a c-section but
it doesn't mean that i didn't become a
super home
in a different way or whatever like you
found it through other means yeah so it
definitely still tapped into all that
you know like c-section moms are still
mama's like you know the whole full
thing i feel ready i think uh
if it were to happen right now
it'd be great because we're going to a
birthday center but no like have you
ever
baby's not ready but i'm ready i think
as a parent i'm like i'm ready ready to
go yeah like i know when things hit code
red i'm ready to go yeah i'm gonna have
to be my rock
oh
yeah to be my protector of my space i
already know it we don't want cord
traction we want uh delay cord clamping
two-step birthing don't rub off the
vernix keep that vernix on we like the
verdicts
don't know what we're talking about like
what in the world are these terms that's
what you're gonna have to learn when you
have a baby
[Music]
just trying to get like a clearer sound
right now it sounds like the whooshing
yeah a background sound
your shirt away from me
135 perfect
[Music]
there we go all right just finished up
it was weird uh being there because a
lot of the workers like kind of somber
very somber vibe like they didn't even
know that they were it's like a sudden
closure like they didn't even know that
they were going to be closing down in
two weeks like
out of nowhere just everyone got smacked
with it they're just like hopeful that
someone will buy it and
continue they can like reopen at some
point i don't know but it's i'm like
what in the world are the odds of this
happening like it's just it's such an un
like it's not a common thing for you to
have your provider and just go out of
business like what it could be worse you
know like we could be about to
go into labor we could be you know their
due date could be a week from now yeah
you know and a lot of people like in
that scenario i feel for them it's such
a big moment in your life and to have
like the chair be like the rug ripped
from underneath you it's like dang
chair works through chair pulls right
from underneath you yeah like i like rug
rug works too drug works better because
i feel like it when you fall when a rug
is ripped from underneath you you fall
oh yeah you know because you're on your
feet where you're having chairs ripped
from underneath you kind of just fall on
your butt so it's not so bad
it's so technical with that one i don't
know why
you're so funny yeah anyway so that's
that that's the last time we're gonna go
to that provider and hopefully fingers
crossed we can transfer over
to a new place soon and continue and
hopefully we can do the vbac thing as
well like hopefully we can give birth at
the birth center yes exactly we were
able to do that here and hopefully this
next one they accept us and they let us
birth there
i am like so crossing my fingers i'm
like please please please please please
for me personally my next option after
like trying with this birth center i'm
gonna try with a different birth center
because there's like two options if they
don't both are like nah then
my next option after that is trying to
get a midwife to do a home birth then
last resort like ultimate last resort is
going to a hospital for me like for me
personally last resort i don't want a
birth at a hospital
yeah me neither i mean i'm not even the
one going through the birth thing
directly it's not my body that that's
going through all that stuff but like i
can tell yeah the hospital is on their
agenda is get you in and out as fast as
possible like i can already feel that
just from the few times we visited the
hospital that we were with yeah but
listen because like i remember
when we were talking about leaving the
hospital to go to midwives there was a
comment that someone was like don't be
[ __ ] on hospital workers pretty much
but i'm like i'm not [ __ ] on
hospital workers
if anything i'm [ __ ] on the
procedures of the hospital and this is
not the hospital workers yeah it's not
the hospital workers fault at all it's
the policies and the procedures and the
way that the culture and the whole
system culture does not respect
physiological birth natural the natural
progression of birth like we're animals
we're supposed to be like in a dark
quiet safe space and hospitals are the
complete opposite of that so
i'm not [ __ ] on the workers yeah
[ __ ] on the policies and the
procedures and the culture and then also
if you look into this ricky lakes
documentary the business of being born
that documentary like freaking mind blew
me and that's what convinced me i never
want to give birth at a hospital you
look statistically like you look at the
stats the us
being a first world country we have a
crazy amount of infant deaths and
maternal deaths
during birth during labor because of so
much so many interventions that are
unnecessary that happen
in the hospital it just leads to more
complications and leads to death and
like it's crazy like how are we in the
u.s and we have babies and moms dying
giving birth at hospital like it's crazy
not that it doesn't happen outside of a
hospital
things happen whatever i'm passionate
about this subject you are very
passionate about it yeah another thing i
learned about uh child birthing why all
this stuff makes sense to me too is you
gotta think of it like a sphincter let's
talk about sphincters real quick
what about sphincters so
the the uterus is a sphincter and of
itself the vagina is a sphincter in and
of itself what else is the sphincter
well the anus is a sphincter
and when you go poop you don't
particularly like being rushed when you
go poop right when you rush then you
have to push and when you push you might
end up getting a hemorrhoid get more
constipated you know like it's actually
not very healthy to push that much
because the pooping is a physiological
process just like earth
and eating and digesting and i saw one
that poops a lot you know since i've
been born
i can relate i don't want to be rushed
when i poop and my sphincter and my butt
is not going to want to be forced to be
open right and so i'm like yeah that
makes a lot of sense and so if the
uterus it's a double sphincter though
the uterus and the vagina they're not
going to want to open up when you want
it to open up and you're not going to
want to push and force it all that much
and so and the idea of being hearing
happens so what that's how tearing
happens too in labor oh yeah true
pushing and then like oh it's just that
i guess we're like subscribing to a
whole new philosophy on uh childbirth
than i am at least like this is all like
really relatively new information for me
but i mean it makes sense i'm ready to
fight anyone that's gonna
try and do the core traction thing or
the one step birth process yeah they're
gonna do the one step and yank on my
baby's head
and i don't want that i'm gonna punch
someone in there
yeah that's funny ready
[Music]
you